citizens of the rejection
will take you away to a Hocus Pocus to
reaction and review today but first I am
joined by the very wonderful and
excellent Sally lamonico salamander
Sally say what's up
what's up reject Nation excellent how
are you doing today are you excited I am
feeling magical as am I we both grew up
on this movie I think we both have a
fair amount of anticipation but also
trepidation it's always a prospect
coming back to something especially so
many years later but I am excited yes
the movie is so nostalgic so I hope
there's an element of nostalgia within
oh they're they're absolutely this
that's the modern currency is Nostalgia
but guys sure before we hop in leave a
like on the video leave a comment about
what you thought of the movie once it's
done also don't forget to subscribe
click that notification Bell and go over
and visit Sally's Channel as well we
will have the proper Link in the
description box in the pin comment Now
search Sally lamonico on the YouTube and
if you want to join us for the full
length Reaction watch along see the
entire experience with us that can be
found over at our patreon page
patreon.com the real rejects last but
not least thank you to the team at
prepper for cutting these highlights
down saving us all that time and energy
and doing a killer job in the process
much love to them and hey without
further ado
it's like that black flame candle let's
Put A Spell On You
[Music]
oh the tone changed this is my new
favorite Disney bumper they need to keep
this
out of my way
[Music]
no well that was enough for me today
some ADR today
[Music]
I discovered a cell dogs grind Pig suits
and mix it with water it creates
mysterious goo and Mary had the
wonderful idea to make a drop of goat's
blood and look it's she go with satanic
jello
[Laughter]
well then getting
same Reverend Trask arranged it said
twits his duty since father died did
Steve say no of course then I took the
lord's name in vain
we searched for the largest one we could
find
us oh man what shall we name it
Tis the Reverend hide answers if we're
not here you gotta fix that lid on there
tighter
definitely give thee one more chance oh
and agree to marry John Pritchett
he's cute I wouldn't allow me a moment
to reconsider yes of course
no oh praise God
I refuse to marry that loved if I shall
marry anyone it will be Billy butcherson
there's Billy my man because we are soul
mates since when since we shared that
kiss in the graveyard
oh blasphemy
I banish thee from Salem forever
Buster Bluth no the
books have agreed to take thy sisters
and turn them right
okay
[Music]
[Applause]
that's a pretty gnarly spider
entomologists
Satan's pets yeah probably
like some soup
that's what I'm gonna say next time I
see a spider yes same unless he's
Spider-Man
[Laughter]
I can help
one Circle
yes
the calming Circle
oh
why'd you still coming to my Woods have
no choice they were gonna take my
sisters go out
different from the other children I have
eaten
it's okay I I mean I wish to be special
that way
this is a very Sacred Space
for witches no wonder I like the woods
so much
right one day Salem will belong to us
us
oh there's the book book
[Music]
I like that she's got it on her dress
too the eye
happy 16th birthday child
but I'm a witch I know things go on
yeah I was way more realistic now yeah
magikai Maxima the power spell oh let's
do this one
it is most frowned upon doomed is the
witch that uses this spell promise Thou
shalt never do it
why uh-oh
because you said so adamant why book
does not like it
so we gotta do that spell the world is
not too fond of witches
can't imagine why it's because thou
eateth children
how else does one stay young and
ridiculously beautiful Adriana Crow
I Ponder this all day nice Cameo from uh
Hannah waddingham of Ted lasso Fame
ring my wrath May
dang
no they shall never take us now we'll be
together forever
[Music]
always had that witchy gleam in her eye
[Music]
foreign
I decided to have two breakfasts
try to come check out Ryan's car we
covered the entire thing in tin foil
why
because it's funny my man's is a hobbit
in another life
hate to see us feet fun yeah if she
wanted to hang out with us on my
birthday she'd probably have hung out
with us one other time in the last four
months I know but still it's our
tradition
coven man
uh about tonight I was dude it's gonna
be our son
what is important
uh oh your dad would never let you do
that it was my idea I told you I wanted
to talk to him about it first oh do you
guys want to talk now
the three of you used to do wish stuff
every Halloween it's not witch stuff and
what's that a good luck charm in case
there's a pop quiz well I hope not
because I didn't do the reading
this is the same
yep Halloween I've prepared the scariest
class possible
a pop quiz
trick
Mr Wilkie's a jerk of course he gave us
a pop quiz on Halloween I made an
inference
is that a spell
this guy is the envy
garban so
now
what did you do these are all food
ingredients you're right garbanzo
garbanzo cacao spirulina did sound like
you said Satan I said Satan I was
literally listing vegan foods see she
admits it that's enough Mike Becca
principal's office now burn her
bet you didn't predict that
[Applause]
[Music]
we actually don't call it The Secret
Circle anymore oh felt uh felt a little
bit dramatic oh that's a bummer oh my
gosh remember when Cassie would bring
like 10 flashlights with us
so you want to come to The Secret Circle
dad
oh my god well listen are you going to
the magic shop yeah can you pass out
some of these campaign flyers for me I
would really appreciate it sure yeah I'm
gonna see you at the festival tonight
look at this am I gonna see you here
yeah okay it's gonna be a good one I
want to go I know Sandy's candy cauldron
what
I love him and listen you have to have
one of her caramel apples it will it'll
change your life promise me I need one
he really is the nicest man alive
it's kind of sad he doesn't realize
Cassie kicked us to the curb
you just get you guys to do free labor
for his campaigns he knows what he's
doing yeah Sanders and sisters
we're the most powerful coven that ever
lived that's right
book of spells
you really don't want people opening
that book huh that's not to keep people
from getting in no it's to keep the book
from getting out
do that I got a Hannibal Lecter mask on
it that is a virgin should light the
black flame candle on all holozies the
Sanders and sisters vowed they would one
day return to take revenge on all of
Salem what's a virgin
a person who has never
lit a candle
sure the black flame candle burned to
the wick if the candles melted then no
one can light it and they can't come
right you are right unless there is
another candle oh no Legend has it it's
on the 16th birthday that a witch gets
her powers and like most Legends I'm
assuming that's based in some sort of
patriarchal fear of funeral aging woke
just the thing for a young Mystic
a penis candle
a little bit what are these Angelica
leaves you burn them to lift curses did
you take some
for you never know when you may be
cursed on Halloween
okay bro
yeah what are you planning over here
another year begins Anew Maiden mother
and prone too we call and leave one
request help our intentions manifest
[Music]
what did y'all think was gonna happen
yeah
don't freak the first sign of a real
magical occurrence
I almost started forest fire
I'll put that though yeah
oh
why is everything so quiet
I don't
oh here it goes you done did it now
sisters
nope
that looked like a pitchfork absolutely
the devil's on brand
[Music]
what what's going on no I don't know
oh cool
okay right yeah it's lightning it's
lightning
uh that would have freaked me out as a
kid
that's cool like I like that there's
literally a spider cross crawling
monitor right I'm not even kidding you
you are you're part of them I'm not even
kidding you the spell worked you're
cursed
times
but I literally can't stop watching them
you're being glamored if we intend to
live past Sunrise we have to brew the
life potion and steal this so fast
[Music]
here we go
we're not teenagers no we only look
young but but really we're 40. you don't
even have to brew the potions anymore
you could just buy them oh buy them you
have just like potions except better
because the Soul's already mixed in
ah no more luring children to their
demise no no they're already demised
Sister Sarah
they brought back the bark
yes here we are
just powerful indeed look observe
sisters
and it is
[Applause]
we're right behind you just um look for
anything that says you
[Music]
real baby's face oh delicious
finish
my favorite feeling that means it's
working
it is the face of a child
I wish I get some salt
why
he's better when they eat us no because
it's pretty
at least that's what Gilbert says to get
people to buy it Gilbert really are you
the Sanderson sister Gilbert's gonna
come in handy guys we're obsessed with
those looks
can I take a photo
good
oh my goodness oh really
[Music]
oh [ __ ]
potions work it's just it's just bad
life
every kind of salt
[Music]
Oh we must fly
on what just like my other one
what about us there's only one that's
and find something anything we must fly
Swiffer classic you're misbehaving
oh my God Aromas rumbas
that's actually pretty cool because it's
still in line with like a broom like
yeah it still cleans your floors in the
trailer I thought it was a hoverboard
and I was like oh God but but roomba's
does
oddly charm me it does
and they look cool yeah don't make me
come over there with this broom
bubbles
I feel like we we should have like a
callback counter or like a drinking so
far there's been like 10. yeah there's
been a bunch
we have to get the book out of here the
witches will be here any second
the book is alive
he woke up
hey buddy
don't open it you dumped it's so
incredible I can't believe this
what an idiot there's your beacon
I am so sorry I had to trick you but you
mean I couldn't let the candle myself it
just it wouldn't have worked well why
not
oh
cause I've lit a candle before they were
ahead of their time and they were
misunderstood they had the whole world
was against them but now look everybody
loves them look at all this stuff
oh my God
oh
did he break anything
the dungeon
uh ow None Shall see your hair be shout
heed my words there's no way out
oh
damn 1993
not a great year for me
bunch of bullies stole all my candy
Jay and Ice that happens you know I saw
you
foreign
who is this man the best the mayor
well I told you we should have the
entire family when we had the chance we
tried but we were too young and too weak
the Magic High Maxima the power spell
uh-oh you can't do that ever do that
spell that must be 100 years ago that
promise has expired
oh
no she gonna show back up must be done
in a sacred place oh
place we are not allowed
[Music]
Hidden Wood
that's our spot
sacred what else do we need the head of
a llama yeah that'd be a bummer because
all of our lovers are gone uh you can
get Billy back
my old lover Billy butcherson
okay sure but you know Billy was my
lover oh Santa you were just playing
let's see what else
ouch I'll have the Sanderson ah glass I
don't I don't think I do problem at all
let's see if you don't have it we'll
just have to kill these
oh you said hourglass with h yes all
right but that I do have actually yeah I
think I misfired you
get it together Gilbert yeah pick a side
man You Shall Gather all the ingredients
and bring them to the Forbidden wood and
if you pay
you forfeit your life
with the last rain
of this sand
yeah
be sure to come to me when I call
no
the replica books
Angelica leaves hey they lift curses
hey if candles can bring back the dead
why can't potpourri bring back the
stairs
but I mean that's a good point
that's not Six Feet Under
he never was
Billy's ready
who are you
[Applause]
I simply wish to know why you were
digging up my grave and I simply wish to
know why you're alive but because I was
woken up and never put back to sleep
well I'm in awake since
how long ago was 1993
oh jeez poor guy bear back again
nope it's like nah I'm out I got my head
knocked off enough times last time don't
you want to pay her back for poisoning
you and sewing your mouth I don't trust
this man
[Music]
shut up
I like to give the roomba's little like
morbly chatter noises yeah like they're
little creatures
little droids yeah lift the curse and
let us out lift the curse and let us out
with the curse and let us out oh
I always thought Gilbert was lying about
this site we need to get Mr traffic
somewhere safe
oh hey Becca sorry to do this but
Cassie's throwing a party oh fun where
at your
what with boys
no let him get his candy out
[Music]
this looks so rude
sweating that's a cool touch
that all I can think of is the Jordan
peel it's like pouring
[Music]
Magic Salt Anderson Sisters costume
contest Looking Good Fellas very
authentic thank you
is that Dan finnerty we're about to win
whatever this is and put your hands
together for
[Music]
do the dance macabre
let's do it I'm ready
foreign
damn I got a whole thing going off
screen
it could but what kind of Mayor would he
be
trying to kill me
[Music]
grounded me for the rest of my life
he went back to the festival to get his
Apple
[Music]
I love this character
are they we'll explain putting inside
now oh my God
they're coming back together
about wherever you die
spread out
sorry I didn't catch that oh God
there is a small woman trapped in that
box
I still don't understand is there
something else I can do for you
[Music]
he got it what happy Halloween after all
oh I wish I knew this dance wow
whoa whoa whoa whoa let's get my Apple
oh hey Sandy no no oh come on no no
poor man you need the juice of an a
rarely Berry for your spell right
this is all the Aurelia juice in Salem
let me out of here alive or I will pour
it out
it does not attractive
to hold a clutch
pandemonium
[Music]
you're trapped that's possible
[Music]
trick she cursed you you were not trying
to kill them you are helping them
the spider what I need your head it has
to be you you were her lover
we shared one kiss
let me explain
no
this guy I swear don't hurt Billy stop
I'm happy to stand back get him God damn
it you are not very great Gilbert
no Gilbert
Gilbert The Jerk why would we want to
hang out with people that just make fun
of us I don't make fun of you guys yeah
you call us witches and say that we're
weird yeah because you hang out in magic
stores and always carry around colorful
rocks and I think it's weird but I don't
make fun of you guys do you hear
yourself
pointing out those differences and
saying that they're weird is making fun
of them
foreign
I've got so many people to apologize to
oh no
who are these women
my worst nightmare if only we weren't
tracked
seriously what's going on
what I got in the dark this pathetic
thing this look at this
I don't even know if there's an apple in
there no this is probably a caramel
covered matzo ball for all I know but
he's had a day
it's a day and a half but if they
explain to him what was going on I know
I mean I guess they tried but they could
have tried harder
ass things must be overloaded by now
I'll tell my mom was sleeping over at
Cassie's she'll be so happy she misses
you
oh Susan
Susan
she can't take pictures of cookies
no what I I don't know
no we gotta get Cassie You Got The Touch
Becca you're not gonna try that if I saw
that I were like go lightning
oh
[Laughter]
Poor Billy's like listen I'm just trying
to exist head of a lover which is butter
Aurelia berry juice and a petrified
spider I guess oh they're still gonna
kill you how do I kill them first
it won't go out until the sun rises you
don't well there's no need for name
calling
yeah man this is all your fault hello
Billy hello you withering hag
well the foul has nothing nice to say oh
[Music]
ah no
ah
[Music]
coming in clutch what Thou Art now
rendered redundant
[Applause]
should we no but what did they just they
just
they'll be fine
I call upon this sacred land
America raise the power in my ass
this guy cannot catch a break I know
who's wants to sleep
Billy's like just kill me man Becca
special
sense none of what's happened tonight
makes any sense
I mean fair enough yeah
[Music]
artwork is full of witch I knew she
smelled off
please
hey
[Music]
get them
I am a good and loyal sister and I
expect to be seen as such
get it
yep he's a good little sister shut up
and get going with pleasure
[Laughter]
you don't want to do the spell you have
a choice and what choice would that be
I'm talking to the book
she's like excuse me what
uh look this is not I mean not not in
front of her but didn't
Satan gave
but hey maybe he's tired maybe he's
tired of uh cow Towing to the sandersons
yeah it's like every 300 years he's just
like nah yeah Satan doesn't God tell me
what to do is there anything that we can
do uh
Magic Eye Maxima no no no I'm not I'm
not like going to Fred I don't I don't
want to be all powerful I just want to
stop that that's why you should do it
what is valued most dearly thou shall
have to trade
Philly
room Buzz
power's meant to be shared who cannot
hide from our power power is meant to be
shared
[Music]
come on
this is my spell and their parasites
leeches enjoying the spoils I remain
I suck her face my love tonight and in
return I ask Amaze Magica
Maxima whoa the flame is out and yet
we are still here
oh oh
um we shall never die
and don't say them
[Applause]
oh no
the power spell
it takes what you value most
not no witch sister no nothing but a
silly child you knew this was coming
Pete
the wind
feeling my fingers already please
don't believe
oh and I know I know I was the favorite
there they will my sisters yes yes and
really the sorrow is such sweet parting
has been my undoing
hmm I think it is my heart
I bet it is breaking
oh I cannot bear this oh
it's like a grinch moment yeah
please will thou help me
what you're willing to give up your
powers my powers are nothing without my
sisters
oh
lost and gone and out of sight
we cast the spell to reunite
as well doesn't bring them back
it sends you to them
okay oh interesting
[Music]
book is crying it's okay where's Billy
is Billy okay yeah his head get blown
off somewhere yeah
don't worry we're here to help
over here you directionless skeleton
sacked he got his mouth open stitches
are all gone you're really butcherson
winifred's boyfriend oh actually no
actually no
but that's exactly right nope
nope thickest I guess once I guess I
should check on cobweb seen a lot more
action he's ever seen in his life I'm
sure he's scared poopless
nah cobweb's got this wait sorry are we
not going to talk about what just
happened tonight because I feel like I
missed a lot or you know it's just a
regular old Halloween oh yeah
do you think Susan left those cookies
out oh yeah
[Music]
oh oh
come in to recruit them
yeah or something
oh did we get another musical number yes
ma'am
wish wish it is Doug Jones again oh yay
nice
I figured like his facial structure
shines yeah but but you never know
[Music]
lunch
[Laughter]
not bad
and Fletcher I need to look up what
other movies she's done look at that
IMDb going it's not often you see a
woman director let's get true little
woman director woman editor oh wow yeah
she directed step up 27 Dresses The
Proposal okay
Hot Pursuit and then some TB
episodes interesting
[Music]
yeah I've got a got a bit of a film all
going I mean this is a cool Legacy
project to take on
I guess we should hang tight just in
case there's something just in case
there's post credit sins
I feel like I don't know I mean you know
they've they've been kind of there could
be they've been sent off into Oblivion
and yet I still feel like there could be
a gotcha so there could be
because she is very powerful
look at that
I'm gonna eat a starburst while we wait
do it is it one of the pink ones
everybody likes the pink ones I ate a
pink one before we filmed this one is
fruit punch
also a choice flave
um
watching a Halloween movie made me want
to eat candy absolutely no you were more
prepared than I was
this is a pumpkin coffee so oh you got
the pumpkin coffee
that's right I was a little bit prepared
it's adult Halloween candy
I didn't kill the spider it's still just
chilling on my desktop
okay I think I watched it with me
I don't know it's just a little baby
spider and I kept like going up and down
like on my computer under my ring light
like my people
are in this movie I don't know when that
happens I usually I just try to be like
hey I'm not gonna bother you you you
don't bother me we'll be cool don't make
it scary stories to tell in the dark
over here but you know
no Live and Let Live Isaac
the spirit of Halloween I will not kill
the spider
it's very soothing it is well I just saw
19 testing coordinator that's a credit
now
that's right
that's right they probably had to deal
with a fair amount of that yeah oh we're
at the music do you like the musical
score kept for the most part that kind
of classic
Vibe yeah classic villain yeah but fun
and fantasy felt fanciful Macabre yes oh
oh here we are
is it the boy thanks
is it the reverence boy
no
another why is there a second candle
what are you playing at cat and you're
not even big so I don't care yeah I'm
actually glad that they let they let
Binks just be me too I would have been
so pissed if they brought them back yeah
it's like it makes sense that Billy
might come back but yeah like Binks gets
to thanks guys still have recipes with
sister yeah pigs are in that
oh my goodness well hey what did you
think what what what's uh what's your
first impressions Hocus Pocus 2 2022.
um
that's what you want to hear no it's not
okay listen that's the way you want to
review to start off
um
um okay so well okay I want more that's
my general consensus after seeing this
movie
it's good but I want more that's a good
way to put that yeah yeah you know what
I mean like go further it's like an
appetizer it can be more we waited 30
years give me more characters give me
more character beats give me a little
more of that horror and then and then
yeah and then twist me around and
surprise me with the feels at the end
yes I still love the first one more sure
I think that's I think everyone will
okay they had they had a lot
to live up to right yeah big shoes to
fill I think the plot was fun they kind
of like filled in a lot of plot holes in
my head in the beginning I was like wait
this doesn't make sense and then they
like explained it so I was like oh okay
it was directed wonderfully I would
agree
it felt like a TV movie
it does does that make sense yeah for
sure I I get what you mean it's like I I
think they did have you know some pretty
solid production values in general but
yeah it does feel more like the TV
special follow-up and and not
necessarily which I'm not mad about yeah
in like the least insulting way you
could say that I don't know how to say
it yeah I think like I was expecting a
different finale
you know like in the beginning when it
started out I love the beginning by the
way like when when they came back and
how terrifying that like it was such an
epic reintroduction I wanted that same
energy of like they weren't scary in
this one like they had moments where it
was like kind of film like a horror
movie and I wish it kind of would have
kept that energy
um I agree I I was afraid like the first
one had so much heart to it
um and you're rooting for the good guys
but then in this one I was like how are
they gonna bring that heart back and
they did with uh Winifred at the end
being upset that she lost her sisters so
I'm like okay there's the heart you know
what I mean
um yeah I wasn't expecting like that
actually got me a little misty-eyed
right I was like that was like
that's a cute moment but it like um
humanized them
and as a way to like actually
ostensibly send them off in really close
the book really close it they sting you
at the end they could always come right
but yeah if this was the end that was
actually felt kind of nice yeah there's
something the original movie has that's
more classic in terms of Storytelling
and also I think they they
I think this movie competes with itself
a little bit between being just a story
about what happens next with the
sandersons and even the things they've
thought of like okay we're not going to
do the same spell as last time we're
gonna you know go for the ultimate power
the ultimate spell the spell that's
forbidden and you know even the way they
brought Billy back we need his head uh
because that's what Winnie thinks she
loved like there were a lot of things
where I'm like okay cool like I feel
like you actually thought of how to grow
this out of the previous one and I think
a time Jump like this is actually kind
of nice for for this situation but yeah
there there is a certain amount that is
also uh kind of occupied with a more
modern sensibility so it's like okay we
gotta be cutting around and we gotta you
know throw in some hip jokes and then
we'll throw in some classic references
and then we'll expand on stuff and so I
think it just makes for yeah just like a
slightly less succinct and graceful
whole but something that's still like
really enjoyable and has the spirit of
the season and of the country that you
know you're in Salem Mass so like that's
a very unique place to be at you know
Halloween time especially yeah so like I
think there's a lot they got right here
it's not like the it's not necessarily
like a slam dunk
um but I I think people would enjoy this
generally and I am certainly not let
down really I feel like I came in with
some managed expectations but you know
optimism generally and for the most part
I thought this was yeah this was fun
not like necessarily essential but but
it had enough unique interesting idea
that's that's that thing I come back to
that it's like it's
in some ways I'm like this had the
ingredients to be like the definitive
like that's the sequel hell yeah yeah no
I think I think they they were very
creative with the plot and I was
actually pleasantly surprised with it
with the with like the way that they
described everything and how they could
justify it being in modern day you know
what I mean I was like oh that's
actually really clever I think that's it
it's like a lot of things feel like
running gags more than it felt like it
felt like a show it felt like a episodes
of a show like the tone of it and then
seeing she directed a lot of shows I was
like okay yeah like the Beats of the
comedy yeah um and stuff like that
um yeah it does have a sort of episode
yeah that's how it felt and then when I
saw that I was like oh okay not knocking
it
um it was just different than than like
it's not obviously movies in the 90s
also have a very distinct like you can't
like do those anymore because they've
been overdone if that makes sense like
yeah there's like a lot of cliche things
in that movie that I'm like okay yeah
you definitely can't do that now but
it's still a classic so they did
modernize it and I get it
um the book having a personality that
was the only part I was confused about
because first one I don't think there's
any indication that it can think
it has like a degree of personality but
it's it doesn't read quite as like it's
a sentient character with its own will
the same way it does here where it's
full-on like no the book is resisting
them and I thought did you like that I
did yeah I thought that was a cool
development I mean the book has an
eyeball in it that looks around so I
think that it would yeah I thought it
was it made it kind of cute like in the
in the first one it's like ew and then
this one I'm like oh like yeah yeah and
I mean like the whole thing where they
go to the to the yeah they go to the
Walgreens and they're they're drinking
all the beauty products and stuff like
that and they find the roombas like
those are those are callbacks but that
build on things
um they don't feel quite as like lurid
to me like I feel like a lot of the
callbacks
a good portion of them at least are in
character which is nice and then you
have your other flashbacks where it's
like oh that's a line they said or
that's a you know a thing that we kind
of have to a bell we have to ring is it
just me or did did you feel like they
were trying to like set up a new show or
something like with the girls it felt
more like that was their goal than to
actually do like a solid Hocus Pocus
sequel that maybe wasn't trying to set
up something else yeah I wonder about
that because I mean part of me I feel
like it ended in a way where with both
sides of the story I'm like these could
easily continue if they wanted to like
they could definitely do a spin-off of
the girls that's what it felt like to me
I don't know I was ex I just wanted more
at the end like they kept uh
the beginning was so solid especially
with the flashback
um and having oh my gosh I'm blanking
was he like a reverend yeah yeah so
having having that character be the
villain and so at the end I was
expecting the mayor to have this big
like moment with them or something and
it didn't have it didn't happen there
were some things that felt like they
maybe got snipped out in editing or
something over time because like
especially the whole thing with the
party at the house yeah felt like it
wrapped up really fast and then we like
rejoined characters after that situation
right it feels like a whole bunch of
stuff happened with them off screen or
same with um to a different degree um uh
what's his name Billy like they you know
go off finding all the ingredients and
stuff like that and and you kind of cut
away from them for a long time and then
once they show back up again you're like
oh that's right you guys are doing
something you guys are on a mission here
and and so yeah there are these and
especially with the mayor uh you know
because once he goes back in the house
after the whole garage thing I feel like
it's kind of that's kind of it and then
the
boyfriend character he was hilarious and
like it would have been funny if also
he'd somehow stumbled at the ending and
been like what like the powers and I it
would have been funny I don't know the
ending yeah maybe it was it was the
ending seemed a little like maybe things
were cut out or rushed or something this
is one of those situations for me where
I'm like I I really enjoyed watching
this and I think yeah as a fan you know
I'm sitting here and I'm like yeah I'm
you know none of my big red flags are
big you know warning lights went off
about like oh you know they're taking it
in a direction I don't like when it
comes to sequels like this or sequels so
hard yeah it's super hard and and
sometimes I feel like for me the metric
becomes is it a sequel or is it the
sequel like sometimes you just know like
ah this is the perfect story this is the
perfect kind of uh you know take for
updating or whatever and I feel like
where I'm sitting right now I'm like
this is a sequel that gets close to
being like V sequel at times it started
off strong for me you know what I mean
yeah it started off starting for me and
then I was like oh sweet like they're
they're gonna keep the same lore and
everything like from the first movie and
like the backstory was fun and it was
creepy
um
and then it just I don't know what it
was it just didn't go there uh for me
like okay a good example of like a
really great sequel that was almost
better than the first movie would be
Pirates of the Caribbean because I kept
the same energy and I kept the same lore
and then they just added to it this one
I feel like
um
had that in the beginning and I was like
oh my God yes High Hopes And then I
don't know
it's weird yeah it's like I'm sitting
here trying to figure it out because
this is a slightly longer movie than
it's supposed to feel longer at all to
me I felt shorter
in a weird way and that's and that's
maybe perhaps my gripe is I feel like
you look at Hocus Pocus and there's
something that's I don't begrudge them
for the story they wanted to tell or the
characters they wanted to focus on it
makes I actually really like as much as
people whinge about wokeness now and you
know female empowerment stories I feel
like telling a Hocus Pocus follow-up
about a budding coven of of young
witches is a perfectly reasonable taken
and something that makes a lot of sense
but also yeah gives you the opportunity
to tell a different story however the
original movie has such a classic blend
of things it's like you got kids moving
to a new town I gotta take my kid's
sister around I don't want to and I'm
trying to fit in I'm trying to be cool
there's a love story and then you have
the Sanderson Sanderson sisters on top
of all that and and like yeah I mean the
Hocus Pocus one movie folk it focus more
on the actual family and of characters
and like you you really get invested
with like the brother and sister her and
like his crash and
um and they have a beautiful character
Arc at the end like it really gets you
with this one I felt like I didn't know
the friends that well you know what I
mean yeah like I wanted to know them
they're the main girls they're like the
main characters of this movie but I feel
like I didn't know their lives that well
so it didn't I didn't care oh that
sounds mean you know I get you it's like
you don't you don't like attached to
them the same way yeah yeah what they
were given I thought they did nicely
with to the point where yeah I I just
kind of accepted them as characters and
enjoyed their their journey and and two
for again like a story of friendship and
empowerment and sort of learning to uh
rise to an occasion and come of age and
embrace a new found gift or ability like
I thought they naturally made that work
in a way that didn't feel like oh it's
2022 and that's the story We Tell right
now yeah you know like it made a lot of
sense for a movie that it has always
been you know at the center has mostly
female characters anyway like I think
that makes a lot of sense
that's true Gilbert no offense awful
character and like you're not rooting
for him at all
I think that I I I the actor did a great
job
I enjoy him I think he's funny but also
yeah he's funny Gilbert is in a bit of a
different movie I feel like
like there's a weird the tone didn't
match for me but he yeah him and and
again my belly I like him and I liked
him and Billy together and I liked uh
Tony Hale especially as the mayor but
there there is an interesting
the Sanderson sisters have a cartoony
almost three stooges quality about them
there is cartoonishness within this
world but I feel like this movie this
follow-up yeah didn't always
I feel like the original one like the
cartoonyness was pretty appropriate and
pretty well placed where is it and it
was it stood out because it was
it was the girls and everyone else was a
little more grounded you know what I
mean yeah and then you would have been
occasional yeah yeah yeah and then you
would have occasionally like uh uh the
kids would come up with some kind of
clever way to trick them or whatever
yeah but for the most part yeah like
everybody kind of lives on Earth uh in
you know heightened 90s fashion but yeah
here it's like there are certain moments
that do and I think that contributes to
its feeling like a TV movie or like a
family TV movie is you do get more broad
like here's a wacky moment with the
mayor here's a wacky moment with Gilbert
and you know like I again like both of
those actors are are fun and I enjoy
watching them but as yeah for the
consistency of tone I wasn't uh like
annoyed or anything by it but it does do
a lot of like
we're doing a bunch of nods to all sorts
of lines and comments you remember I
love the uh the nods to the original
film
but yeah I was like wondering where the
uniqueness would come from it and I
guess the characters like the girls let
me just how do I put this my mom as a
Christian woman
would have let me watch Hocus Pocus as a
kid
she would not have let me watch this one
as a kid if that makes sense in terms of
message it makes sense yeah I was about
to say and especially I don't know if uh
I you know the rules are different when
it's just a streaming movie but I was I
kept thinking to myself like oh there's
no way they can play this in China
no the message is definitely different
in this movie than it was in the first
like as a kid I was terrified of them in
the first movie because they were bad
and in this movie I feel like I wouldn't
have been scared you know what I mean
yeah yeah because they they
do it's in the characters again to to be
Fish Out of Water and to get wacky and
you know the original movie picks and
chooses to do that and I love that too
and I think the the three Walgreens bit
was fun yeah yeah and I mean Bette
Midler Kathleen uh Jimmy and Sarah
Jessica Parker like I love watching them
together still I really like their
comedic chemistry back and forth
together
um you know like their performances are
on point but there's also that and I
mean I like it in the context like we
talked about the ending where it's like
oh you know like what is something that
actually matters to this character
that's not gonna feel trite her sisters
are gone that makes sense
um but yeah that was done beautifully by
the way even though I I think I wanted a
bigger ending I think that that one was
still shot directed and acted
beautifully because it did get me it got
me you know what I mean like the way she
delivered those lines I was like oh my
God and that was a cool way to end it
off because we've seen them Outlast the
Dawn and that's true though yeah freeze
up and explode and all that and so yeah
it was a unique ending as a way to do
something different and also as a way to
solve the problem but without a big
Powers battle I think is a really good
touch
um especially if you do want to
you know have some kind of empowerment
story going to I think that's kind of a
neat solution and I'm also surprised
that they embraced as much as they do
like I I kind of got a kick out of you
know we live in a time and place where
people are much more aware of uh
metaphysics and you know now there are
witchy stores all around and you can get
crystals and herbs and whatever else and
then some more mainstream thing and I
was kind of surprised that they were
just like yeah that's what these girls
are into and by the end one of them's
gonna be a witch and they're gonna have
their own little coven and we're cool
with that uh because you know there'll
be white witches instead of you know
dark magic witches my little my little
Christian self is like oh no
the amount of girls that are going to
watch this movie and want to go do that
stuff I'm like
oh man and and that I mean in a way
takes me back to that older time where
I'm like cool you know and and I think
it's funny like there are things in here
like they confront uh it's like a virgin
can only light the black flame candle
that was funny I was like yeah I can't
light it yeah and I feel like that the
original movie is probably the movie
that taught me that word but even then
like they have the little boy like ask
like what's a virgin and like you know
when you're a kid watching it it I think
a lot of those things go over your head
and when re-watching the original one
there are a lot of subtle things
especially like the way Billy acts
toward Winifred the whole time like
there's there's subtle things that are a
bit more adult that come to the surface
um and and they're those are present at
times here they had Hocus Pocus playing
on TV which I didn't quite understand me
off I don't know what that was yeah and
because if he saw them as a kid for so
at first I remember thinking did the
first movie even happen and it wasn't
until that he explained that he saw them
as a kid in the 90s I was like oh okay
because in my head I thought they were
gonna like skip over that movie and
because in the beginning it just seemed
like that's the route that they were
going but then he did say that he saw
them in the 90s but then the TV thing I
have no idea what that was it reminded
me I don't know if you saw the recent
Pinocchio but they have uh there's
Geppetto has a wall of clocks yes uh
cuckoo clocks and they're all branded
Disney
property clocks and it reminded me of
like a way less obnoxious version of
that but where you're still like wait
wait hold on how does this work how does
what does this make the rules of this
like is Hocus Pocus
is that now ostensibly like the film
made about the events that happened in
1993. do you think they should have
brought back the original Trio at all or
no
the original Trio of kids um yeah I
think I was thinking they were gonna be
like teachers or something and like
so that would have been good cool yeah
that's a good point I mean I know Thora
Birch doesn't do much acting now I can't
remember what her story is like the
brothers the brother was kind of like
the lead I guess but sure yeah I mean I
I have a strong association with the
three of them and I'm a little surprised
now part of me is like I wonder if they
maybe showed up as they they didn't seem
to show up in any kind of like here's a
cameo that's clearly a cameo you know so
like if they are maybe they're in the
background someplace yeah I'm just
saying that would have been fun it would
have been fun for at least like one of
them to have been like a a character in
this it's like wait
they're back I don't know but then maybe
that would have been cliche I don't know
I wasn't thinking about it now that
you've brought it up it is sort of like
an interesting it's just as interesting
to me that they didn't as it would have
been if they did you know yeah I think
either yeah that makes sense yeah and
it's like it's not something that the
movie is hurting for or anything because
yeah I mean part of the the point is
getting the sandersons and and Billy I
guess and and any black cat back
um and I appreciate yeah again that they
left I I kept expecting it to be that
the I was like please no please no yeah
don't bring like I think that's the a
good sign of like yeah they approached
this with a reasonable amount of I
wouldn't be surprised if they did do
that and then like did a screening and
took it out afterwards like because they
had that black cat in it a lot yeah see
I feel like this movie had its heart in
the right place enough that it that that
probably wouldn't
I don't feel like that was in the mix
I think like the tease is good enough
but yeah I mean you never know what
could have been cut out but yeah yeah
overall I mean you know especially after
so much time I got a kick out of this I
had a it made me feel you know kind of
warm inside even if it didn't always
like nail it I still think it was like a
pretty
solid update like this could have been
so much worse
um and I'd be happy to kind of watch
them back to back and I'd be curious to
know what the people this is more aimed
for think of it because I feel like
there are a lot of callbacks for people
who grew up on that movie but it doesn't
feel like it's quite aimed directly at
those people no it feels like it's it's
putting things in there for us but I
feel like it's still definitely aimed
towards
um like the teenage or pre-teen
demographic for sure yeah like pre-teen
I think but like the production values
like the Aesthetics and stuff like that
like the shop and the woods and the
Beautiful giant Moon that's always
looming over and the different costumes
and stuff no it was beautiful and I
think too like the opening uh sequence
with them when they were younger was
solid the actors were so good they
played younger versions so well I was a
little worried about that aspect because
I was like ah you know like going back
to the origin isn't always necessary and
it's the thing and then I was like
waiting and I was realizing like it
didn't really come back it kind of did
in conversation of like oh we need the
blood of the reverent and whatever but
other than that it really didn't
but it does thematically like I
appreciated that I liked it as the theme
because it it at least reflects the
journey that then uh Becca and her
friends will go on you know the six the
coming of age 16 years old it kind of
mirrors flowers unlocked when they were
around 16 ish I guess in that flat
flashback versus like you know the new
girls now than them I did really like
them doing the walk at the end that was
that was really great to tie it in there
are a number of things they do too to
also make it a little more meta or
self-aware where they're like who are
they singing why are they singing who
are they singing to and and uh other you
know there are other ways in which they
do that and I thought that was I feel
like they could have done maybe more
with that because I feel like they were
mostly doing that just to kind of answer
just the general people's question like
I feel like in the in the original movie
there there is song perhaps a bit more
gracefully Blended in I was gonna say
yeah yeah and so like on the one hand I
like that they come out like I like that
there are ample opportunities for them
to sing and to do the you know
harmonizing all that stuff together but
also yeah it is that's another very sort
of modern very now thing of like you
know who are they doing this for why are
they and I thought you know I
appreciated them commenting on it I
could have used maybe like a better
payoff to that but these are like all my
gripes are just like little things
that's little things there's like a fair
amount of like little tweaks and and
things that I think could have been
finessed but um but yeah I mean all in
all especially after some of the sort of
Disney reboot things we've seen lately I
think this this is a pretty decent one
overall you know the three of them are
just terrific together like that's a joy
in and of itself because I love a good
witch story anyway but I think you still
get that Halloween vibe that I think is
very special because you know not the
Halloween movies for Halloween time are
fewer and further between than you know
the grand majority of horror movies yeah
and I definitely felt that and even
though you don't get a ton
of character fleshing with the trio
um because it's pretty much just their
Rift with their friend and and them
growing apart and this thing with her
boyfriend and you know it's like the my
character whatever his name was the
goofy football player like I like that
thread
um and I thought it was a neat way to
flip the bully story but even in the
original one it's like you know uh Jay
and Ice have it's just that thing it's
like it's a little more well-rounded
here it feels like he's a funny side
character who shows up every now and
again and is funny luckily that's why I
thought he'd come in at the end at some
point and tie it together uh like like
with you know the other bullies in the
first movie where they end up in the
cages that was funny but yeah I think
this they didn't do a lot of tying of
motifs or of characters they didn't do a
lot of tying around
that's where I'm like
I think that's where the comment of oh
it felt kind of rushed at the end a
little bit came in but
I'm also thinking if they shot this
during a pandemic yeah I mean I could
have had a lot to do with it yeah and
for a while now we're gonna be kind of
handicapping movies that way and I think
that is you know that that lens
that's part of the classic it's like the
original movie has these classic story
beats new kid in town you know young
romance blah blah blah but it it also
has that classic nature of like okay
everything that's brought up that's
prominent gets you know touched on or or
uh paid off in some way
um you know like a like a spell
um and so yeah I think that that
contributes like a lotion episodic
feeling no like a like a serum
you can see him um but yeah no I'm a
happy camper though generally speaking
I'm a Happy Clam I was just happy to see
them together again yeah after what 30
years yeah that did not disappoint like
after so much time like the three of
them together and and you know like I
could have I can always take more of
that
um I wanted more I think that's why I'm
sad because I wanted more
it didn't feel that long to me but I
guess it was that's a good thing though
like if the pacing was very fast so
that's good I'd rather have it feel
shorter than than feel like it's
dragging on yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
because even if it's not always
symmetrical or doesn't always like
gracefully tie things together chances
are they move on to something that's
amusing or endearing or fun in some way
or spooky and and yeah like I'm not
looking for a reinvention of the wheel I
like that they put those touches in like
when they show up the first time and
they are kind of in these strobing
effects and they do have this scary sort
of imposing quality like those flavors
you know if you're talking to me as a
cinema fan I'm like go further with that
that's what I was saying in the
beginning I was like I wanted them to go
more with that horror aspect that would
have been sick but yeah because but
there is a third right
a third Hocus Pocus
it's kind of what they were
we'll see how this does again it could
always if this is a hit you never know I
feel like nowadays they have to leave it
open just in case I
think there will be a third I don't see
why there wouldn't unless people really
don't like it but
sign up get get your Disney plus
accountants 100 times to make sure and
yeah I mean sitting here I would happily
if they made a Hocus Pocus three part of
me would be like please don't mess this
up don't mess this up but I but as of
now I would be happy to return again me
too they've set up a whole new group of
characters it'd be fun to see more yeah
um since I feel like they didn't get to
go that deep with this one because there
was a lot there to pack in you know what
I mean yeah sorry Gilbert I hope you get
I hope you get a third movie Gilbert
yeah and he's gonna be the lead next
time I I need to see some Redemption
Gilbert What's Eating Gilbert that's
that's the last thread that's the third
movie okay yeah
yeah and I mean yeah I mean those those
three like I would be curious to see
where they might go in this world I
thought those three actresses did a nice
job together especially the two they had
big shoes to fill and they filled it
yeah and without having to do the exact
same thing the previous movie did and
and even though it is different yeah
yeah and even though it is centered
around like you know these
these you know this Trio of friends who
are having you know drama between them
and you know oh there's a boy who's like
tearing us apart and and all that and
and you know there is I don't know it's
usually that the boys an [ __ ] and
he's just stupid and it's so funny yeah
and I mean he he is but in a more fun
but in like a in like a fun like oh poor
soul kind of way not like the
stereotypical like oh we hate your
boyfriend
um I could definitely see that I'm doing
like us like a show with the girls you
know I could just see it with the spell
book and everything and I'd be curious
to see how they would how they would go
I think you always know this universe
begs that you have the you know classic
over the top you know uh you know 17th
century speaking witches but even so
yeah and who knew that the book is the
new Banks I know yeah oh yeah see it's
it's they have enough clever twists and
enough clever ideas
to to make it stick so yeah so yeah
we've got some some good some good
makeups too some good music
um yeah took me back yeah good for them
good for you guys
well alrighty thank you for joining me
salamander Sally this has been fun
thanks for having me absolutely we'll
have to get another one on the books
soon but for right now folks out there
in the reject Nation leave us your
thoughts on Hocus Pocus too was it
everything you hoped it could be was it
nothing you hoped it could be or was it
kind of in the middle somewhere also the
one thing they did leave out is that
it's just a bunch of Hocus Pocus am I
right they didn't say that I didn't
think say it I was waiting for it it's
just a bunch of Hocus Pocus too
says
well that's why they have to make that's
why they have to make part three then so
they can just to say it come on guys
they got one more Easter egg reference
to pay off they did every other callback
but that one yeah all the children all
the ingredients for the spell except for
one
yeah
well all right leave a like comment do
whatever you guys are gonna do and we
will catch you next time much love
cheers happy Halloween happy Halloween
[Music]